the Joe Rogan experience like do you see
the Tyson Fury Deontay Wilder finest all
clips ho oh my god were you there no no
I watched it home holy [ __ ] holy gasp
period Oh phew six seven almost no six
nine
Deonte six seven Furies 6-9 6-9 270
pounds and he just figured he figured
out in the first fight that Deonte in
the 12th round he started back at the
ante up
Deonte can't fight backing up because
Yount a is a guy who pushes forward he's
get this ridiculous power right and
everybody scared of power so everybody's
moving all the time and fury realized in
the 12th round after Deonte knocked him
down almost knocked him out he got up
and started chasing Deonte and Deonte
fought sloppy he'd said he looked
awkward he said his footwork didn't look
so good technique yeah both Deonte is
known as being this guy who's got an
eraser his right hands like an eraser
all the mistakes
Teddy out let's put it this way all the
mistakes of the previous rounds all get
erased with one punch he just shuts
people's light Tahlia and he has that
confidence that he has that eraser power
but with Tyson Fury realized like look
Tyson doesn't fight that way Tyson Fury
fights on his toes he sticks and moves
did a lot of head movement and a lot a
lot of like shuckin and jivin and he it
makes it very difficult for you to
figure out what he's doing like is he
going here is he going there is he
moving as he jab but he'll come at you
like this with 2/3 fake jabs then a jab
at a right hand he'll throw a right hand
to the body then he'll throw a left
uppercut he'll step to the side of you
throw a right hand he'll move out of the
way a poppy with a jab as he's moving
away he's like a very technical like
really sophisticated boxer if you look
at the movement that he does for someone
as big as him it's really kind of crazy
and it's not that he couldn't step
forward and smash people and knock
people out and says he knows the sweet
science yes you know he knows the sweet
science but then he realized for this
fight he had to fight a different way to
shock Deonte he had to come at Deonte
full blast get in his face from the from
the jump and that's exactly what he did
he also trained changed trainers and he
went with Sugar Hill who's a
trainer Kronk is where Tommy Hearns came
from you know Gerald McClellan and some
of the great like knockout artists of
the past and crop gem from a manual
Stewart was known as being a very
offensive style of fighting they have
heavy jabs they don't touch you with the
jab they're smashing with the jab big
power in the right hand like Kronk was a
tacking aggressive style like they were
all known like they would wear those
Kronk shorts those yellow golden shorts
you saw a guy with Kronk shorts on that
[ __ ] came to kill you
they've they thought in when they were
in the gym Emanuel Stewart would turn
the heat up to 100 degrees so when they
were doing they were doing like hot yoga
in in the [ __ ] krump gym because he
wanted to build up endurance in these
guys so when you would go into the crunk
gym in Detroit it was hot as [ __ ] like
really hot and that's how he force
everybody to train under extreme duress
he was a amazing amazing training he's a
guy who rejuvenated wladimir klitschko
when Vladimir Klitschko was falling
apart because he hadn't gotten K out a
few times
he his style just he didn't have like an
American style he had this like sort of
straight-up European style and Emanuel
Steward just shifted his style and and
just made him concentrate on utilizing
that long reach and the big power that
long jab so when Tyson Fury went with a
Cronk trainer for this like he was vet
dead serious he was gone for
seek-and-destroy he told everybody
that's what he's gonna do too but nobody
believed him everybody thought it was
just a hustle like him saying and go to
knockout Deontay Wilder I'm gonna come
after him I'm gonna knock him out in two
rounds everybody's like you're out of
your [ __ ] mind even Deonte was like
you don't believe a word you're saying
you're just talking you're not gonna try
to knock me out that's exactly it
figured out the puzzle he figured out
the puzzle in the 12th round of the
first fight he just realized when he had
him backing up he's like oh this guy
stumbles on his feet he gets all awkward
you got him backing up yeah so he just
just forgot to like glue he took that
out that's what I wanted to talk to you
about
I want to start fighting man no no my
son needs to know
[Applause]